We're going to be working over half
of the stitches on the needle bed.
Start by determining which needle is going
to be used as the center,
and mark the needle bed with a pencil.
This mark can be easily erased and will
help you keep track as you're transferring
stitches, especially if you're
transferring groups
of stitches across the row.
You'll see in a minute that I didn't
remember this trick until I
knit my second set of transfers.
Cast on stitches as instructed and make
the first decrease, emptying a needle.
Then hang a transfer tool on those first
couple of left-hand needles for safety
so they won't fall off in the next step.
Pull out all of the needles on the right
Slip those stitches to the garter bar,
and try to open the latches
as you remove the stitches.
This isn't critical.
You can always open latches, but it
helps if you do it with the garter bar.
Transfer the stitches left.
When you rehang the stitches
from the garter bar,
you'll be filling in that empty needle,
and you'll have one last stitch
on the right finishing your decrease.
Don't forget to remove that safety
transfer tool. Take that emptied needle out
of work before you continue knitting,
and knit two rows.
Repeat this process,
making sure you work your decreases
over the same needle each time.
Done correctly, you'll have shaped your
piece with the decreases
and have a decorative seam.